but let me continue on the line of
absurd questions
so you it talks about um you know deep
connection of the humans deep connection
with the
ai meaningful connection let me ask
about love people make fun of me because
i talk about love all the time
but uh what what do you think a love is
like maybe in the context of um a
meaningful connection with somebody else
do you draw a distinction between love
like friendship and facebook friends
[Laughter]
or is it a graduate no
it's all the same no like is it just a
gradual thing or is there something
fundamental about us humans that seek
like a really deep connection uh
with another human being and what is
that
what is love eugenia
i'm wondering i just enjoy asking these
questions i like that
seeing you struggle with them thanks
um well the way i see it um specifically
um the way it relates to our work and
the way it was
the way it inspired our work on replica
um i think one of the biggest and the
most precious gifts we can give to each
other
now in 2020 as humans is this
gift of deep empathetic understanding
the feeling of being deeply seen like
what does that mean like that
you exist like somebody acknowledging
the somebody
seeing you for who you actually are and
that's extremely extremely rare
i think that is that combined with
unconditional positive regard
belief and trust that
you internally are always inclined for
positive growth and
believing you in this way letting you be
a separate person at the same time and
this deep
empathetic understanding for me that's
the that's the
combination that really creates
something special
something that people when they feel it
once they will always long for it again
and something that starts huge
fundamental changes in people
um when we see that someone accepts us
so deeply
we start to accept ourselves and um the
paradoxes is that's when
big changes start start happening big
fundamental changes and people start
happening
so i think that is the ultimate
therapeutic relationship that is
and that might be in some way definition
of love
you